graduates guests
faculty and staff
welcome to the 2021 msx graduation
ceremony at the stamford university
graduate school of business
11 months ago you arrived here at the
gsb
and i welcomed your class over zoom
i am so happy that we are here together
in semex
we have definitely come a long way over
the past year
now
before we begin the ceremony i'd like to
start by recognizing our guests the
families and friends who have provided
support and made the effort to be here
today
let's have a round of applause for our
guests
and i'd also like to share a brief video
message of congratulations from
stanford's president mark tessier levine
good afternoon and congratulations to
each of you on earning your masters of
science and management
during your time at stanford you've
explored intellectually refined your
skills
and reflected on your careers and your
goals for the future
i'm always impressed with our msx
students for taking the time to invest
in themselves and advance their
knowledge
but your cohort in particular took on
this task at a deeply uncertain time
you persevered through a delayed start
adapted to new ways of learning and
built a strong community
despite the challenges you faced
the spirit of leadership determination
and commitment that you honed through
this experience will help you
immeasurably throughout your careers
your hard work and dedication have
brought you to today and i hope you're
all tremendously proud
as you join the ranks of stanford alumni
i urge you to use your talents and the
skills you've honed here to shape the
lives you want to lead and to contribute
to our broader world
i can't wait to see what you do next
congratulations once again on your
remarkable achievements
[Music]
[Applause]
a graduation ceremony is about
celebrating what you've achieved and
what you will go on to do
and i'd like to start by looking back
and let's start by rolling back the
clock to the fall of 2019.
you were all leading your lives
very successful lives by all counts
spread out all over the globe in more
than 20 countries working in different
industries finance healthcare tech
education
government many of you had advanced
degrees already many of you had children
spouses mortgages
you were leading teams
the mortgages part yeah you had
you were leading teams you were some of
you had started organizations
and yet
you wanted something more
you wanted to think
about your career your life
how you might take it in a new direction
or to the next level
you were dreaming bigger
and that led you to stanford
or you thought that was leading you to
stamford
of course march 2020 rolled around and
had other plans for all of us and the
gsb like the rest of the world
had to move online and your path here
became much less straightforward
we made a difficult decision to postpone
the start date of your program making
you unique
in the history of the gsb
and of course you had many factors to
consider
your jobs your family
visas housing expiring gmat scores
not to mention maintaining your own
physical and mental health at the onset
and that of your family at the onset of
the pandemic and you had to answer a
basic question would it make sense to
put everything on hold
and come to stamford for a year to study
business and to study leadership in the
midst
of a global pandemic
well you're here so clearly the answer
was yes
and martin luther king
junior once said
you don't have to see the whole
staircase
just take the first step
you took that step
and you didn't know how the program was
going to go or whether we would be able
to resume in person learning whether you
would ever meet
the faculty members in person or your
classmates for that matter
you took that step and you
took a risk and that says a lot about
you
individually and collectively
and over the last year you moved from
interacting with each other over zoom to
sharing classrooms with your cohort to
the super summer
and now to the fall quarter
and you came together as a class
you planned virtual kids events
you held msx moments conversations with
professors and other speakers at evgr
you even drove around apparently in a
pickup truck helping your other
classmates move
you took paths to power with jeff
pfeffer
david kreps pushed your knowledge of
microeconomics
jennifer ocker enlightened you about the
relationship between business and humor
you refined your leadership skills and
interpersonal dynamics and managing
growing enterprises you earn the
admiration of our faculty
in fact some of our faculty are now
advocating to teach their classes in msx
only elective
[Applause]
you've taken the time to think about
what you want to do do you want to
change your career maybe start a company
with someone you've met here or maybe
you've realized that you want to return
to your job to your industry but with a
new perspective
the magic of being at stamford is being
exposed to a breadth of people of ideas
of skills of different approaches to
management and leadership
one thing is certain
there will be many opportunities for
each of you in the years to come and i
hope
that when you remember this year
you will remember it both for the
opportunities it created and for the
people that you met
and for the chance that you had
to reset and reflect on your own
aspirations
about how you wanted to pursue the next
phase of your career and your lives
and i hope you will do that
in ways that are filled with meaning and
contribute to the greater good
you are graduating at a time of enormous
change
an acceleration of technology a
rethinking of work the opportunity
to build and reshape organizations
and with the skills and the knowledge
that will help you go on in business to
tackle
some of the great challenges and changes
of our time a time of disruption and
change is exactly the moment when a
stamford education is the most valuable
and more than other classes perhaps more
than any other class
you've learned how to deal with
uncertainty and with ambiguity to be
adaptable to be resilient and those are
powerful lessons for your career and
your life
msx class of 2021
congratulations i wish you all the best
and now i have the great pleasure of
introducing our graduation speaker
nishin hashemi
a graduate of the msx class of 1993
nucin is a tech veteran an entrepreneur
an investor a philanthropist she is the
founder and ceo of january ai
a precision health tech company that
harnesses the power of artificial
intelligence to prevent predict postpone
and manage chronic disease
nuchine also guides a family office that
includes investments in over a hundred
companies
she is a co-founder and president of the
hand foundation
dedicated to building better communities
by enabling the growth and advancement
of individuals
she has received numerous public honors
this including the summer the world
economic forum recognizing her and her
company
january ai as technology pioneers
nuchine is also a dedicated alumni of
the gsb
and member of the stanford community she
serves on the advisory board of the
stamford institute for economic policy
research is involved in the school of
medicine and is a member of the gsb's
advisory council where she is invariably
the most involved enthusiastic and
engaged participant in discussions about
the school and the future of business
and leadership please join me in
welcoming nishin hashemi
[Applause]
good afternoon
thank you dean levin
faculty family members and friends and
hello sm msx class of 2021
it is a true honor to be celebrating
this important milestone with each of
you today marks the end of your time as
a gsb student and the beginning of your
journey as a proud gsb alum
not only will you feel deeply connected
to this venerable
uniquely entrepreneurial and
impact-focused institution for decades
to come
but you will also cherish the enduring
friendships that you have nurtured
during your time here i know these
things to be true
from my personal experience
while every class is special in its own
way this class experienced something
truly extraordinary a global pandemic
that appended our world and shut down
even places of worship with which had
remained open during two world wars
consequently the fate of this class
convening on this magical campus was up
in the air for a long time eventually
four cohorts rather than the usual three
were admitted and the year kicked in to
gear first virtually and then in person
and here's the kicker with no mbas in
sight
as members of this preeminent school of
leadership your class ideated
advocated and negotiated the amazing
super summer
the most coveted mba electives taught
just for you
demonstrating their characteristic
generosity and care the administration
and faculty obliged and showed up during
summer after all so much of leadership
is about showing up
you had 11 electives wow when i was a
student here we only had two
however i must say that those two proved
life altering
in jeffrey pfeffer's power in politics
among many cognitions
i learned that whistleblowers who risk
everything to do the right thing are
often feared
and not trusted
small business with jim collins planted
the seeds of entrepreneurship
warned of people who go back and forth
too many times when accepting a job
offer
and gave us lasting concepts like big
hairy audacious goals and having the
right people in the right seats on the
bus
you seem to have enjoyed classes like
new ventures touchy-feely strategic
communications paths to power and
managing growing organizations with your
beloved dave dodson
moments of adversity present our
greatest opportunities and what may have
started as a challenging year for the
msx class of 2021
ended as one that was truly remarkable
now on to the future this pandemic won't
be the last world-changing event that
you will witness in your lifetime
in reality
it is only one of the first
the rate of change is accelerating
but no longer in a singular direction
historically we have experienced one
major revolution at a time
our species became anatomically modern
about three hundred thousand years ago
in east africa
around fifty thousand years ago we
became behaviorally modern gaining the
ability for
symbolic thought
around twelve thousand years ago we have
evidence of early agriculture and the
first stationary settlements around five
thousand years ago writing
a mere 250 years ago the industrial
revolution and the rights of capitalism
during the lifetime
of many present here today in the mid
1990s the information age
more recently the lives of almost
everyone here have included the mass
adoption of the internet and the mobile
revolution
you don't need to be a statistician to
see the trend
as our collective knowledge and
coordination capabilities have
exponentially increased the time between
each revolution has exponentially
decreased
today the speed has become so rapid that
we are in the midst of multiple
revolutions concurrently
as they are not all pointing towards and
they are not all pointing towards the
same future
furthermore
not only are these revolutions happening
at the same time
they're also interacting
with and altering each other resulting
in highly unpredictable outcomes
you're all aware of big technological
phenomena like the metaverse genomics
and gene editing
3d and 4d printing and manufacturing 5g
autonomous vehicles natural language
processing voice interfaces and chat
bots
cloud and edge computing blockchains and
nfts
cobo cobots and robotic process
automation which will affect every
single industry what about smart devices
smart used to just mean connected
now it generally means powered by
machine learning algorithms
smartphones use ai to prove
smartphones use ai to improve the
quality of our pictures a smart car will
use facial recognition to see if we're
paying attention to the road and alert
us if we're getting
tired soon smart toilets will use
computer vision to analyze our stool
samples and inform us of
gastrointestinal issues
with iot universities hospitals and
museums
whole cities in fact can become
intelligent
proving easy access providing easy
access environmental comfort and
security
remotely or autonomously piloted drones
and unmanned aerial vehicles have
changed the face of military operations
we will see them transform search and
rescue missions firefighting law
enforcement and transportation
drone taxis anyone
on the life sciences side
mrna technology of covid vaccine fame
can be deployed to address a range of
infectious diseases and even cancer
we've been wearing continuous heart rate
monitors for a couple of decades
but now more and more these smart
watches are becoming health devices
healthy people are wearing continuous
glucose monitors and not too long from
now we'll see continuous ketone and
lactate monitors i'm personally counting
down the years to continuous insulin
and
the ultimate sensor cortisol monitors
cortisol in forms of chronic stress
which triggers immune and inflammatory
responses increasing susceptibility to
diseases like autoimmune cardiometabolic
and mental diseases as well as cancer
multiomics integration where we combine
wearable data with data from exposome
epigenome microbiome metabolism proteome
transcriptome genome screenom and other
ohms will deliver whole person
precision health where at scale we can
predict just about anything about a
person's health
on the horizon we are seeing nuclear
fusion which if we can bring into
reality will provide inexpensive
unlimited zero emissions electricity
cellular agriculture which produces
animal products from cells rather than
entire animals can change the way we
produce foods like fats and proteins
our increasing ability to understand
materials and control matter on a tiny
or nano scale
is giving rise to exciting new materials
and products such as bendable displays
and inconceivably fast computers
capable of solving seemingly intractable
problems will make our current
state-of-the-art technology seem archaic
these combinations of permutations
are endless and their outcomes
unprecedented and mostly unimaginable
underlying and overlaying
every single one of these revolutions is
ai
itself the most transformative force of
all
machines will learn
and act intelligently
and remodel and reshape humans and our
planet in unforeseen ways
but is this all better
is it all for the better well
has facebook connected or divided us
robots handling mundane tasks are good
how about robot police officers handling
mobs
brain computer interfaces can help
disabled people move their prosthetics
but they can also help militaries take
over minds of their human soldiers
ai scientists believe
that we'll get to asi
artificial super intelligence where
machines become self-aware and surpass
the capacity of human intelligence and
ability by around 2050.
hopefully as a cit as a civilization we
take our time with ai and develop it
responsibly and safely increasing the
chances of ending up with a friendly asi
that solves every problem on earth
including poverty climate and aging
it is not beyond the realm of
possibility though that governments
militaries and rogue actors rush towards
ai in a way that leads to a not so
friendly asi
hastening the end of our species
if this sounds over the top consider the
fact that asi can come about in ways
that we can't even imagine our brains
are not even capable of
predicting the things that can happen
what else is happening around 2050
unless water is used unless water use is
drastically reduced severe water
shortages will grip the planet
the world bank warns we might have more
than 200 million climate refugees
just think about it one million refugees
destabilize europe and split the uk
the international union for conservation
of nature and natural resources says
that if current trends in overfishing
ocean warming and pollution continue
will run out of seafood by 2050.
without a doubt these trends and
importantly the tech accelerated rich
poor gap
is likely to lead to massive social
unrest
so
what will be the source of calm
the beacon of stability
the gospel truth
who will light our path to peace and
happiness as the 13th century poem and
philosopher rumi said the universe is
not outside of you
look inside yourself
everything that you want you already are
i believe that you can find your essence
if you look at the data from your own
life
objectively
this requires taking a metal look at
yourself
and zooming out of your job
your family your network your company
even your country
if you look for meaning in a specific
destination
only if i had this title at that company
only if i started my own business only
if i bought that home or became a member
of that club you risk setting yourself
up for failure in a volatile world
those destinations may change overnight
as many of the many of them did with
kovid so defining your success
too narrowly can lead to disillusionment
instead of aiming for a destination
seek out a direction
let's call that your north star
the nexus of what you're good at
what you love
and what the world needs
it will set you up for success and
continuously provide meaning no matter
what turn the world takes the first
thing to understand is that what you're
good at
your innate power derives from your
natural talents proclivities and
competencies areas where you have force
multipliers if you spend a minute on
something that takes others three
that's your superpower
so how do we discover what we're good at
do we ask our partner consult our
performance reviews
survey our friends
do we see what we've written on resumes
or backtrack from job descriptions we
want to have
those can be valuable but are often
shaped by narratives and norms rather
than the data and insights from our
actual lived experiences
rather than trying to catch our
reflection in others mirrors we can take
the time to do the work to reflect and
introspect
find and look at the data
we inherit powerful methods to get to
the bottom of things from principles of
need finding in design thinking
to get
the right data in front of us we need to
ask the right questions
in this case the devil is in the
semantic details
you don't want to ask a rephrasing of
the answer you're looking for like what
am i good at
that would query your preconceived
synthesis and notions that are likely
riddled with bias towards your past
decisions or future ambitions instead we
want to query the raw experiences
themselves and see where those take us
that way we can cluster up from the data
itself
in this spirit a question you could ask
that would help you understand what
you're good at would be
when was a time that i experienced flow
by using the word when we can recall
specific instances instead of
pre-synthesized notions and flow
as you may recall is getting so immersed
and absorbed in doing something that you
lose sense of time
it is the intersection of a task that
has high difficulty
and one in which you have high
competency
so looking for flow implicitly queries
things that you're good at
the idea here is to see ourselves in all
our dimensions
as competencies are not topic specific
even if they express themselves in a
specific domain the higher level skill
is translatable
now that we have our question we can
ideate the answers
posted notes on a big blank wall is a
good way to capture your answers you
want your sponsors to be movable so you
can group them
once you have your experiences laid out
say 50 to 100 of them cluster them by
activity type to see the patterns once
you have your clusters you can meta
group these to see the highest level
trends or your flow zones
these are high level competencies that
are domain agnostic like analyzing
synthesizing presenting or
teaching this is the overall method for
each question that creates your north
star
not only for finding what you're good at
but also what you love and what the
world needs
first you pose a question that queries
raw experiences related to that larger
question next you recall as many
experiences as you can then you cluster
a meta cluster to find patterns
after finding what you're good at we
layer on the topics that you love
when did it feel like play to do that
thing that you're good at as opposed to
it feeling like work
when did it feel like play
to do that thing that you're good at as
opposed to it feeling like work
this clustering reveals the passion
zones and you will arrive at what is
actually you and not just the way you've
been presenting yourself
often we adopt the passions of our
parents
or those
that our heroes believe to be worthy
we should acknowledge and honor their
passions but following them is taking
the path of least resistance it's easy
to do what others want
us to do because it makes money or is
socially celebrated but these external
sources of passion erode our agency and
make us susceptible to damage when big
changes happen
we need to hunt down our own assumptions
before a turbulent world does
steve jobs killed the enormously
successful ipod to give life to the
iphone
management consultants and investors may
have advised them otherwise
so far our quest for the north star has
been focused on us
what are we good at and what do we love
but to try
but to truly find a direction in life
that is nourishing to us all the
research shows it must also be
nourishing to others
with that in mind what does the world
need from you
you can start to unpack this by asking
when is a time i felt called to serve
once again practice your design thinking
methods flare out and focus in
generating as many instances as you can
possibly think of
going back to your earliest memories as
a child
then cluster and metacluster to find
your purpose zones
now you should have the meta clusters of
what you're good at what you love
and what the world needs from you your
nerd star lives at the intersection of
these three insights
often our job
addresses only one if we're lucky
leaving us playing catch up on the other
two in our free time
and for many of us neglecting them all
together
by looking at our data
and following where it points us we can
work in a way where every minute of work
is nourishing us threefold
intellectually emotionally and
spiritually
you may have noticed i didn't mention
material fulfillment
this is because a you know how to make
money
that's how you got to the top business
school in the world b it's overvalued
and ubiquitously covered already and c
it does not guarantee peace of mind
joyful relations or health indeed
it is often
our hyper focus on material accumulation
that deteriorates those sacred and
meaningful things
remember this
every breakthrough in science comes with
a breakthrough in models
you can't make quantum computers or
nanobots or nuclear fusion using models
from a world that excludes these
possibilities
to become a radically better leader
to guide your own life and to positively
influence the lives of others during
these turbulent times you need a new
model
and we all know
what a good model needs
good data
the more objectively you collect data
about your life
the better your model and the great
leader you will become
our hyper dynamic world needs sober
stable and energetic leaders as mx-xers
you have already taken the step to pivot
and retool
now peel off the accumulated dead weight
of destinations narratives and norms and
find your north star
i leave you with four parting thoughts
born of my own lifelong quest for
meaning and impact
one learn design thinking
master it use it in your work home life
with friends and in philanthropy
two
your biggest contribution to the world
may be taking care of the people around
you and especially your kids
raise your kids yourselves
spend time with them
get to know them well
in this superficially connected world
deep connections are priceless
have empathy for your kids the world
we're handing to them is stormy
have high expectations of them but do so
in the context of the world today
not the one that your parents lived in
when they were raising you
and this advice applies to mentees as
well
three
health is wealth
to pursue your north star
survive the next pandemic and to thrive
in an explosive world
be as healthy and bio-resilient as you
can possibly be
this is a bit hypocritical because i
struggle with this myself
yes i'm a work in progress
as you know the warranty runs out around
age 40 years around age 40.
so take time to establish a new
baselines
try a neuropsychology test for cognitive
function and finding your superpowers
it's not too late to discover how you
learn and lean into those gifts and
insights
take a full body mri which can be
predictive and tilt the odds in your
favor
take your eeg and ekg early detection
blood and stool tests
and take them again every few years to
see how you're trending
explore omics wear monitors and dial
your lifestyle adopt healthy habits
food especially fiber
is our biggest level of health
four stay engaged with your class make
point of visiting your classmates when
you travel celebrate each other's wins
and kudos and shout outs with kudos and
shout outs convene on quarterly zoom
calls and organize reunions take
advantage of stanford's abundant
educational opportunities including the
d-school institute of human centered
artificial intelligence and the new
school of sustainability and give to
stanford
a lot of people
gave a lot of themselves to make this
experience possible for you be a good
ancestor
and leave good things behind for future
generations
class of 2021 thank you thank you in
advance for the solutions and
thank you in advance for the solutions
to the problems of people and planet
that you will be introducing to our
world and for the novel blueprints of
humble and human-centric leadership that
we will no doubt
design along the way we will all be
beneficiaries of your collective
contributions and as your fellow
stanford alum i will be cheering you on
you've always given you've already given
me great hope for the future
congratulations
[Applause]
thank you very much nasheen that was
great advice
especially for the parents out there i
thought that was uh quite quite helpful
and uh a nice perspective on a lot of a
lot of topics so thank you so much
nasheen for taking the time to be with
us and for those words
uh it is my honor to present the msx
teaching award every msx student takes a
core curriculum covering topics in
accounting
data and decisions ethics finance
marketing microeconomics negotiations
operations and strategy organizational
behavior
and strategy beyond markets beyond these
core courses students also take a wide
variety of electives at the gsb
each year the msx class votes
to award a faculty member with the msx
teaching award and this year the voting
process was coordinated by msx academic
officers catherine garlinghouse
yuki madote midoto madota i'm sorry
about that
and uh kacha
pacha nihina
thanks to the three of them for your
work on this
so uh they they worked very hard because
they had 67 nominations for 22
instructions instructors
it was obvious that many instructors
many of whom are up on the stage
are beloved by the student by the msx
class in disciplines ranging from
accounting finance and economics to
marketing management and
organizational behavior
one instructor however made a
particularly lasting impact on this
class and it is my great honor to
announce that the winner of this year's
msx teaching award is david dodson
described by many as simply amazing dave
went out of his way to make class
interesting and useful
it was obvious to the students that dave
has genuine care for student well-being
loves teaching
and as truly contagious i would almost
say infectious energy that was present
in every single interaction
multiple students commented on dave's
efforts to alleviate the experi
to elevate sorry about that to elevate
the experience of msx students and
create a learning environment truly
tailored to this special community
practically speaking dave
as always was incredibly well organized
effectively taught students about useful
toolkits to align both personal and
professional goals and change the
definitions of success happiness and
risk taking
finally multiple students commented that
dave is more than just a teacher
he's a mentor and a life guide whose
closing remarks at the end of the
quarter were described as truly
breathtaking and memorable
one thing that makes this award so great
is that dave was
truly as excited and enthusiastic about
his summer teaching
as the students were about having him
teach them
long before dave knew he was going to
win this award he was raving to me and
others about his summer msx mge sections
so congratulations dave and thank you so
much for all your contributions to this
class's academic experience
the late r.j miller who was the dean of
the gsb from 1968 to 1978
founded the certificate in public
management and social innovation program
here at the gsb
the certificate program educates leaders
who understand societal issues
design for and evaluate impact and
understand the
specificities of the management of
social organizations in both the public
and the private sectors
in a world faced with dire global health
equity and sustainability challenges
today's certificate programs take the
spirit of our gsb motto change lives
change organizations change the world to
its full potential
from this msx
cohort we have 11 certificate candidates
their names are listed in the program
and i offer you all congratulations on
completing that
[Applause]
um
we will be announcing graduation awards
at a later time as final
calculations are going on as we speak
those awards include recognizing the top
ten percent of the class as robert l
joss scholars
bob joss who this is named after has
joined us today so thank you for being
here bob
and about six or seven of you will have
be attached to bob for the rest of your
lives
the top student in the class the person
with the highest gpa in in gsb classes
will be awarded the george
g c parker award
george uh
had
full intentions of being here today i
think he got his regalia and was all set
and at the last minute
was called away to another meeting that
he couldn't possibly admit
miss he sends his regrets and he asks
for he asked me for an excused absence
which i'm going to go ahead and grant
him
but
we will be happy to announce the winner
of that award very very soon
before i hand over the podium i wanted
to just say a few things about the msx
class of 2021
since march of 2020
though i i can't i'm so sick of saying
unprecedented i cannot tell you
um you know it we throw that word around
too much and you know there's a lot of
stuff that's been unprecedented but it
is an understatement to say the
challenges faced by this class were
unprecedented they were truly
exceptional
as a group you showed amazing resilience
in waiting six extra months to start the
program
you arrived in the bay area
at
basically the high point of the epidemic
and um you did the first half of the
program
with hardly an opportunity to leave your
apartments and meet your classmates so
and and
uh we those were amazing challenges and
you all
faced those and made the best of it and
we really appreciate that despite that
this class was an extremely academically
engaged group
and you found a group of leaders and i
want to give a special shout out to
felipe j.y catherine nicole katya hannah
i've probably forgotten a few others and
i apologize for that i want to give a
special shout out to all of them for
their dedicated work
that group i mentioned and some others
were dedicated advocates for all of you
as their classmates they truly were and
they were wonderful partners to the gsb
administration for which we're very
grateful
so i want to thank them and all the rest
of you for your flexibility and teamwork
to make the most of this very
challenging time and of your overall gsb
experience
this is the end of the journey and it
was very different from what you
anticipated when you applied to the msx
program i know that like any msx class
it's a transformative experience and
your lives have been forever changed and
while a lot of the experiences you
envisioned had to be altered and were
constrained i hope you will look back
fondly on your time here at the gsb
and uh i also hope you're going to stay
involved with the gsb
are moving from the student community
into our alumni community and as i hope
you've already seen our alumni play an
important part
in the academic experience here and it's
my wish that you two will engage with
the gsb's
academic mission as alumni give your
time and experience experience
generously to future classes
i could say a lot more about what the
msx program can mean for students but
who better than our graduates to talk
about their experiences this past year
if i had to choose one word to describe
my experience it would be transformative
my one word to describe this year is eye
opening a word to describe my msx
experience this year would be great
exceptional unforgettable my experience
in msx is filled with love family growth
transformation if there's one word that
i could use to describe my experience at
the gsb is believe
amazing exciting inspiration
transformational the word that i'd use
to describe my msx experience is on
world opener life-changing mind-blowing
exhilarating incredible i came in with
an idea of what it might be like but
i've been constantly surprised at every
turn by the people that i've met the
experiences that i've had and just the
overall energy of this place before i
came i was doubtful but i am sure this
was the best decisions i ever made this
year at the gsb had changed my
definition of success happiness and
taking risk the relationships both with
my class and across the gsb are what has
made this experience truly spectacular
for some of us confidence can be a
revolutionary thought and the gsb
community
the students alumni professors has been
giving me all the reasons to believe in
myself
as they are my role models in their
beliefs of making a change for this
world
it is the people the students the
teachers alumni
that make this place so special the
thing that surprised me the most about
my time at stanford was how humbling it
can be now there were certainly a lot of
areas where i felt that my talents and
strengths were reinforced but this place
challenged me i'm unequivocally most
grateful for the people that i've met
here
i love gsp
i love stanford and i love my family who
strongly supported me throughout the
year stanford made my world bigger i
enjoyed every single day of the program
stanford has opened my mind to new ideas
expanded my view of what i'm capable of
and connected me with lifelong
relationships what the nsx has meant to
me
understanding that there are no crazy
ideas the thing that i'm going to take
away from this experience is the
stanford mantra
it's to change lives change
organizations and change the world
and i'm going to do that in the
healthcare space
i love you all thank you so much it was
amazing here
isn't that a great video thank you
everybody who contributed even those who
couldn't stick to the one word limit
um
finally i'd uh i'd like to now introduce
associate dean margaret hayes who will
read the names of msx degree candidates
as they walk across the stage
so
hadish batu
[Applause]
tiffany ashley bell
bill alexander banesse
[Applause]
daniel bernstein
trip patia
[Applause]
zachary blaisdell
katrina carey
[Applause]
marty tommy lynn chin
hannah j cho
[Applause]
vicas chaudry
theo two
[Applause]
mali coimbatore
luis carlos cruz
dido
isabelle de andrade
[Applause]
alexi dunaway
catherine lilly french
jose matias fuentes matioli
catherine elizabeth garlinghouse
[Applause]
kunal ghosh
anirud golvakur
[Applause]
felipe freitas
mimi gupta
[Applause]
june hanida
sarub jane
yacine luxery
leon lauq
when you lay
ryan leonard pay
j y lynn
nabil mansouri
[Applause]
[Music]
michael john matamo jr
yuki misota
[Applause]
morgan joseph o'brien iii
jason oma honey
[Applause]
giacomo pellegrini
pablo rivadenera hertado
[Applause]
kate manning rogers
michael seden
[Applause]
eduardo liel
james patrick schreffer
[Applause]
maria fernanda sierra pereira
katya sol
nicole christina renee swanson
michael titus
[Applause]
josh vanderlip
tomas vargas
[Applause]
andre ventura fernandez
lindell wilson
prashant yadav
[Applause]
yamaguchi
lee
[Applause]
alexandra lauren yick
lulu you
shan you
[Applause]
ryan gian joe
edmond joey zhao
[Music]
nicolas
[Applause]
[Music]
graduates guests faculty and staff this
concludes the 2021 msx graduation
ceremony
at the stamford graduate school of
business
i have to say that seeing all of you up
on that screen talking about the program
and walking across the stage leaves me
with a great feeling of optimism and
hope for the future
and before we leave the auditorium for
the reception in vitilakis courtyard
which i hope everyone will attend
let's have one final round of applause
for the graduating class
[Applause]
so congratulations msx class of 2021 and
now let me ask the guests to please
remain in your seats we will recess out
from semex auditorium the faculty then
the graduating class and then please all
join us across the street
at vitilakis courtyard for the reception
so
congratulations class of 2021.
[Music]
so
you